what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be diving back
into the action-packed insanity of the
black clover spade kingdom
war arc asta is now stronger than
ever before and he may have just
unlocked
the most overpowered ability in all of
black clover
anti mana zone full power asta
is fighting it out with the strongest
devils that we've seen so
far in the story and the stakes are
massive so let's get into it
if you guys enjoy our black clover
videos and you want us to keep it going
just leave a like and a comment
it only takes a second but it actually
does help a lot with the youtube
algorithm and of course if you're new to
the channel or maybe you watch our
videos regularly but you haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you simply
can't trust youtube to show you our
videos
unless you subscribe hit that bell and
select the option that says
all by the way huge thank you to our
anime opera patrons for supporting our
channel and making content like this
possible i'll talk more about patreon at
the end of the video but for now please
be advised that this video will contain
black clover manga spoilers please
proceed with caution you have
been warned the latest installment of
the story starts off with finral
saying that asta decided to run
headfirst into the spade kingdom castle
ahead of the other black bulls that is
exactly what we've come to expect from
asta by now and let me tell you it is
definitely a good thing that asta
decided to rush in
because if he showed up even a moment
later knocked would probably be
dead instead asta managed to save
knocked by cutting off
nama's arm and then he protectively
placed himself between
noct and the two devils we then see
guimodelo crying and begging noct
not to die because apparently if he dies
then the devils that he made a contract
with will also be
in danger seeing gimodello cry over
knocked like that was both
sad and kind of adorable and you just
know that guimodello and the other three
devils have an emotional connection to
noct
this isn't just a contract of
convenience as is the case with most
other devil users
and their devils noct and his devils
seem to actually
care about each other i'm not sure what
exactly guimotello meant when he said
that if noct
dies then his devils won't be safe but i
am interested in learning more about
that
maybe that depends on the nature of the
contract
itself because i definitely can't see
lucifer dying
if dante is ever killed lilith and namah
even said that dante was just lucifer's
toy
so i'm like 200 sure that if dante died
lucifer would be just fine
this whole exchange between gimodello
and noct reminded me that we still have
a lot to learn about the connection
between devils
and devil users and there is a lot to
learn about how exactly that
relationship
works now noct is of course happy that
asta is finally here because he believes
that asta will turn out to be the key to
defeating the devils
and the dark triad but noct says that he
and his own life don't really matter in
the grand scheme of things
no matter what happens to knocked in the
end as long as the dark triad is
defeated he will be happy
he's basically telling asta not to focus
on helping him but to focus on the
battle
and if knocked dies then it's no big
deal but
osta shuts down that line of thinking
real quick
he tells knox that his life most
certainly does matter
because if it hadn't been for him asta
would never have gotten this strong
so asta wants noc to live and to see the
full extent
of asta's new power a power that would
have been impossible to attain
without noct's help ever since his
brother died
noct felt that he should have been the
one to die instead of morgan
he blamed himself for his brother's
death and he felt that the good
kind and noble brother died and the
selfish
unworthy and dishonorable brother lived
knocked seems to have believed that
dying in battle as a magic knight was
the only way to make up for his tragic
decision to summon
lucy fugus the tragic decision that led
to the death of his brother
so basically knocked entire purpose in
life since morgan's death has been to
atone for his
sins by sacrificing his own life in a
noble way for a good cause
noct seems to have felt that this was
the only way to stop himself from
feeling that terrible guilt that he has
felt
every day since his brother died and
that must be why
during this battle against the devils
noct has repeatedly and frequently
talked about
sacrificing himself it's like he already
made the decision to sacrifice his life
ahead of time and he was just looking
for the right
opportunity but asta is trying to tell
him that the purpose of his life
isn't to die in this battle his purpose
is to live
and do good in this life things that
matter
and things that will make a difference
in the fight against
evil and of course this includes
training asta
and allowing him to attain such a great
level of power
and in this moment noct sees his own
brother morgan
in asta asta is exactly the type of
selfless
honorable and heroic person that his
brother was
even though asta never met morgan his
spirit and his
attitude embodies the essence of who
morgan was
and so in a metaphorical sense a new
morning
anu morgen has arrived however
asta quickly reminds us that his new
epic power-up
does have one serious limitation one
minute has already passed
since he first entered his devil union
mode
and that means that he now only has 4
minutes left to defeat both lilith and
amma
before his time runs out and he has to
let go of the devil union mode
but far from looking defeated lilith and
the ma
are ecstatic in all the hundreds of
years that they spent in the underworld
they never had this much fun they've
never encountered such an
interesting challenge and they can't
wait to unleash their full power
against asta meanwhile inside of us
liebe is fully conscious and he has a
wide grin
on his lips liba clearly recognizes
lilith and namah and he says that he
never thought that he would meet
them again in this world this confirms
the fan theory that lieben knows lilith
and them
from before from back when he still
lived in the underworld
and this little fact makes the upcoming
fight
even more interesting this is no longer
just a fight between osta and some
random devils these two devils likely
bullied and abused liba
in the early stages of his life so now
this fight is personal it is about
revenge that personal connection between
liba and the devils
raises the stakes even further and it
gives liba
additional motivation but this also
means that liebe could lose his cool
during the battle and do something rash
something that might hurt his and asta's
chances of
winning the fight hopefully not but you
never know because
liebe spent so many years focusing on
his hatred against the devils
and plotting his revenge lilith and the
moth then
launched their devil ice and devil fire
magic directly at asta
but asta uses black hurricane to cut
through
and dispel both magic attacks asta then
chases after lilith and the ma
trying to slash them with the demon
dweller's sword
but the two devils are extremely fast
they are able to dodge
osta while at the same time pursuing him
as a predator stalks
its prey rather than being scared of
asta after seeing what his auntie magic
can do
lilith and emma are just having fun and
playing a game to see who can kill
us the first after realizing that his
current strategy
isn't working and being aware that he
has to end this battle
as soon as possible osta pulls out the
demon slayer
and demon destroyer swords but here's
the thing
asta's demon destroyer sword looks
different now
it's as if the sword itself has gone
through a power up
along with osta it seems that the devil
union mode is having a real physical
effect
on the sword as well and not only does
the demon destroy her sword look
very different it also somehow manages
to negate
all the magic in the immediate area
including of course the magic of
lilith and namah the two devils are
confused about what happened
how did their devil ice and devil fire
magic just
disappear and while they're standing
around confused
asta grabs the demon slayer's sword with
his other hand
and slices through namas body on
that crazy and potentially game changing
note
the chapter ends whoa
does this mean that asta unlocked the
ability to create some sort of
anti-mana zone with the help of the
demon destroyer sword
so instead of being able to manipulate
all the mana in the surrounding area
as with a traditional monozone ability
asta is able to
instantly negate all of the mana in the
surrounding
area that would be so insane and so
overpowered and you better believe that
anyone who encounters this ability for
the first time would be caught off guard
and thoroughly confused which of course
allows asta to take advantage of that
brief confusion
and attack and that is exactly what he
did to nama
wow what an amazing fight this has
already been
but we know that it can't go on for long
because of how limited
asta's time is so does this mean that
asta has already defeated nema
and now he just needs to take down
lilith or
is defeating these highest ranked devils
going to be more complicated than that
like for example is it possible that
lilith and amma can somehow survive
being cut by anti-magic by regenerating
extremely
fast or can they maybe fuse into a
single devil since they do appear to be
twins and may be part of one greater
whole
personally i don't know how this battle
is going to play out but i can't wait
to find out and of course even if foster
is able to destroy both of these devils
in the very next chapter don't forget
that he still has to take out the dark
triad
and any other potential devils who
emerge from the tree of cliffhoth
in less than 4 minutes there is no way
that he can do all that
in less than 4 minutes so this battle is
likely going to continue for some time
i'm guessing that asta and liebe will
probably be forced to return to normal
for a while
and then they might be able to enter
double union mode again
later on either way though asta's new
power-up is so freaking hype
and the fact that he might just have
unlocked some sort of anti-monozone
is just huge this new power is an
absolute game changer but as powerful as
devil union
is that five minute time limit is a
serious limitation
especially in a massive battle like this
which includes like hundreds of
combatants
definitely let me know what you guys
think do you like asta's insane devil
union power up
and do you think that he just unlocked
some sort of anti-mana zone
and if so do you think that he will be
able to crush
all of these devils on his own or is his
time going to run out
before that happens hit me up with your
thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this black clover video and you
want to see more black lover content
right here on the channel
you know what to do leave that like it
only takes a second but it helps a lot
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you can also hit me up
on twitter and
instagram at animeopror
a big thank you to all of our anime
uproar patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to the two disciples
of lord tuigo himself
alpha sigma and the red-haired raven and
i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata acquired
respect
pate heffa liam thompson algertol dr
cortman dustin scarlett
the toasted chi bang emperor taku spidey
life chanel big buddhist
tungsten tarkis and yuno finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp rathundera
very gucci alicia octor bonnie parks
hinokami and water joanne garcia ted no
ted isparky65 jessica lafond
fat boy games deadly saint and soul ray
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar gives
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos
along with these legendary people as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you